si efectivamente
dentro de su discurso de campaña el
ahora presidente electo rodrigo de
chávez
planteó la posibilidad de solventar vía
referéndum aquellos proyectos de ley que
él considera neurálgicos para su futuro
gobierno en caso de que no fructificaran
en la asamblea legislativa tal cual
hemos estado mencionando a lo largo de
todo este especial don rodrigo chávez y
el partido progreso social democrático
únicamente contarán con díaz diputados
de 57 muy lejos por ejemplo los 19
diputados que contaría el partido
liberación nacional que es la fracción
más numerosa en la asamblea legislativa
se ha comentado y se ha analizado por
especialistas en derecho de nuestro país
que la propuesta de don rodrigo era el
de solventar vía referéndum aquellos y
aquellas iniciativas que no prosperen en
la asamblea legislativa pues sí tienen
determinados límites establecidos por la
constitución un tema en el cual don
rodrigo ha sido muy enfático en que
desearía eventualmente convocar un
referéndum es en lo que costaría que
llamamos las pensiones de lujo que
básicamente es aquellas pensiones que
reciben determinados altos jerarcas
dentro del sector público que si son
considerados y que chad y que arrastran
una gran impopularidad la porque en la
población costarricense entonces don
rodrigo de chávez ha prometido solventar
vía referéndum este tema sin embargo
constitucionalmente las pensiones son un
tema que expresamente quedan excluidos
de la posibilidad de realizar cualquier
tipo de referéndum junto con materia
presupuestaria materia tributaria
y
determinados actos de naturaleza
administrativa
entonces en dado caso de que don rodrigo
chávez pues quiera insistir en su en su
post en su propuesta de llevar vía
referéndum pues allí será sometido a
prueba los pesos y contrapesos que
tradicionalmente llamamos de una
democracia como la costarricense si hay
que hacer la salvedad de que él no dice
abiertamente que va a realizar un
referéndum sobre pensiones sino que va a
realizar un referéndum sobre la
posibilidad de que la sala
constitucional nuestro tribunal
constitucional
tenga la posibilidad de interpretar
la misma carta magna y sobre este tema
que como mencionó el tema de las
pensiones de lujo de las así llamadas
pensiones de lujo ha sido un tema
sumamente impopular en los últimos años
y bueno don rodrigo pues ha acumulado
ganado determinado
votante que si considera que esta es una
iniciativa en la cual un eventual
gobierno debería avanzar sin embargo
como mencionó una iniciativa de este
tipo por mencionar a una de las de las
muchas que se pueden mencionar pondrán a
prueba el sistema de pesos y contrapesos
la relación con los medios de
comunicación tradicionales también es
otro aspecto en el cual la democracia
costarricense se verá pues sometida a
prueba entonces sí serán años quizás de
conflictividad y de
desencuentros del gobierno de la
república como estas otras instituciones
que son pilares de un régimen
democrático como el costarricense